في غضون ذلك نقلت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان مقربين من رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو في حزب الليكود يبحثون
خطه لاستمرار حكومه الحرب في حال استقاله
الوزير في مجلس الحرب بن جانس واضافت
الاذاعه ان الخطه تشمل تعيين رئيس حزب
اسرائيل بيتنا وزير الدفاع السابق اكدور
ليبرمان بدلا من يوف جالاند في وزاره
الدفاع
ينضم الينا من حيفا الكاتب المختص في
الشان الاسرائيلي ايهاب جبارين سيد جبارين
جنس لن يستقيل الى حد الان ولكن من خلال
تصريحاته ما حجم الخلاف بينه وبين نتنياهو
جانس يتحدث عن ان الاولويه هي لتحرير
المختطفين على حساب العمليه وان هدف
العمليه هو عدم وصول حماس مره جديده
للسلطه ما حجم الخلافات وهل ستتسع
ببقائه نعم تحياتي فداء ومساء الخير
بطبيعه الحال هنا يمكن القول ان بدايه
بركاتك يا
لهاي وهاج يخرج ب نتنياهو بتصريحات
الدبلوماسيه ربما لم نسمعها منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب وهذا العدوان في ربما هي اكثر من
ذلك بل مجرد فقط
معاكسه للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بل حتى
يمكن القول انها بمثابه رد للجانب
الامريكي كذلك اذا تم تقاطع ذلك مع
تصريحات جانس بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر بمثابه
رد الجانب الامريكي عندما خيره ما بين
حكومه سوتش وبين فير وما بين
حكومه تكون اكثر توافقيه مع الجانب
الامريكي هذا الامر الذي يجب ان ناخذ معي
الاعتبار ولكن نعم هنالك الكثير من
الشروقات كل الشروق التي كانت ما بين جانس
ونتنياهو لم يتخطوها ابدا وباعتقادي لن
يتخطوها كذلك بطبيعه الامر بعيدا عن كل
المشاكسات والمداهمات الموجوده حاليا
بينهم بل اكثر من ذلك يمكن القول ان وان
كان هنالك تقاطع في التكتيك ولكن في نهايه
المطاف المصالح مش عفوا
الاستراتيجيات هي التي تختلف نعم جانس في
نهايه المطاف هو يحاول ان يكون الشخص
الاكثر رسميه الاكثر احتواء الذي يحتوي
الكل ويضم ال وبطبيعه الحال هو يحاول ان
يخاطب يعني حتى في خطابه هو استعمل مصطلح
شليح الرسول او المرسال اي بكلمات اخرى هو
مرسال المعسكر الاخر في داخل هذه الحكومه
هو مرسال المحدث عن انه باق ما دامت
الحاجه له مستمره ولكن ما هو تعريفه لهذه
الحاجه يعني في نهايه المطف ربما كان صرح
بذلك ب اشكاليه الاسرى وجزئيه الاسرى هذا
من جهه اولى ب يمكن ان ناخذ هذا بعين
الاعتبار ولكن هنالك كذلك مرم اخر اهم يجب
ان نتذكر ان الولايات المتحده ضغطت لدخوله
الى هذا الى مجلس الحرب هذا منذ الايام
الاولى لكي يقود الجبهه الشماليه لانها
بكلمات جدا بسيطه هي لا تثق لا بقدرات
جلنت ولا بقدرات بنيامين نتنياهو على
اداره هذه المرحله باي شكل من الاشكال ولا
حتى بيتفق بانهم لن يستطيعوا او لن يعني
يقدموا على الهرب قدما
حتى
وان تطلب ذلك افتتاح جبهات جديده الشماليه
تحديدا دون غيرها فقط لكي يلوذ بنفسهم من
الفرار من كل الفشل المدوي الذي بدا
بطبيعه الحال يتسرب الى داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي من اعداد القتلى واعداد الجرحى
وعدم تحقيق الاهداف وهذا هو الاهم في
نهايه المطاف فلله من ذلك يمكنهم افتعال
جبهه جديده شماليه بدون ان نشاك ولهذا
السبب وجود جانس باعتقاده ويوثق هذه
الامر بل يمكن القول انه
عربون ثقه ما بين هذه الحكومه وما بين
اداره بايدن بكل ما يخص جبهات خارجيه بشكل
عام طيب في ظل هذه الخلافات التي تعصف
بالحكومه استقاله جانتس هل استبعدت ام
اجلت في
الحقيقه سؤال جميل يعني حتى لنبدا
من المعطى الاخير يعني بكل ما يخص ليبرمان
يعني انا باعتقاد ان جزئيه ليبرمان هي
معاكسه ومشاكسه للبيد ول جالنت على حد
سواء يجب ان نتذكر ان في حاله اطاحه بجانت
ال جزئيه بان يكون هنالك حاله من التمرض
حقيقيه في داخل الليكود تكون لها يعني
اسهم اكبر بكثير مما هي عليه الان جلنت
بامكانه ان يقود حركه تمرد نحن نتذكر
القوه التي كان عليها في 30 من مارس
الاخير وبالتالي هذا ما يخشاه بنيامين
نتنياهو بالفعل اضف الى ذلك بان ليبرمان
كما كنت ذكرت وزيرا للدفاع السابق كان
لديه الكثير من التعهدات والتفوه بشان
القطاع من اباده للقطاع وما الى ذلك وهو
لم يقدم على اي شيء نهائيا بل هنالك من
يقول بان طائره اف 16 واحده لم تطير فوق
القطاع في عهد ليبرمان فبالتالي هذه
الجزئيه لن يسمعها الشارع
الاسرائيلي او الشارع القاعده الشعبيه
لبنيامين نتنياهو بدون اذن شك باذن جيده
بان يتم تنصيبه وزيرا للدفاع فبالتالي
تبقى جزئيه الى اي مدى جانس يمكنه البقاء
باعتقادي الجزئيه الانتخابيه لطالما لن
يكون هنالك ضور على القاعده الانتخابيه
وعدد المقاعد في الاستطلاعات جنس سوف
يستمر في وجوده في داخل هذه الحكوم